First the New York Post reports
that drive-ins are thriving this year.
Uh-huh, that's right.
An industry that had become just fun nostalgia
is poised to continue and grow as a business,
even as the winter months bring the cold weather.
Many drive-ins are modernizing online ticketing,
ordering concessions like hot cocoa via the app,
and in car electric heaters so you can save on gas.
And in a year where having a sense of community
has been so tough,
drive-ins have been a nice rediscovery.
Yes!
(audience clapping)
Kicking it old school!
Okay, next up,
People magazine reports that a study
from the University of Rochester found out
that watching TV and movies
can actually make your relationship stronger.
It's not just Netflix and chilling,
the study found that couples who engaged in conversation
after watching a movie or a TV show
saw a 50% reduction in divorce compared to a control group.
It's the conversation after watching
that keeps you together like,
oh my gosh, Bruce Willis was dead the whole time?
I love you, honey.
No wonder you're not fighting.
You're zoning out to the boob tube all day.
Who's watching your kids, by the way?
Oh, you don't have them?
Well, you know what's also good for relationships?
Anesthesia and staring at a screen
while not communicating and bickering about daily dilemmas.
So yeah, put on those horse blinders and a muzzle,
and enjoy that relationship.
(audience clapping)
Here's one for all the gingers and Archies out there.
Today is national love your red hair day.
(audience clapping)
Two red-headed sisters created this celebratory day
as a way to celebrate their hair
and empower their scarlet peers.
So let's give a shout out to all our favorite redheads.
Prince Harry, looking splendid as always.
Lucille ball, the OG, yes!
My hero!
Elizabeth I, mm, yes.
Sexy cartoon red-head Jessica Rabbit.
I'm not naughty, I'm just drawn that way.
Ginger Spice.
Fun fact, the only Spice Girl that's actually a spice.
And my personal childhood icon Pippi Longstocking.
(audience clapping)
She let me know I could do anything.
Her monkey's Mr. Nilsson and her horse is Old Man.
Her two best friends are Tommy and Annika.
Does anyone know Pippi Longstocking?
I love red-heads so much,
I even went as one for Halloween.
(audience clapping)
That's right.
We had the best Halloween, you guys.
That was just amazing.
All right.
And finally, PopSugar reported on a feline habit
that all cat owners are way too familiar with.
It's when they stick their butts in your face.
It turns out that experts say
this is the way your cat lets you know she trusts you.
Oh!
Evolutionarily, it's a vulnerable area,
and being in that position leaves her exposed literally.
So the next time that happens,
just give your cat a loving scratch and say,
gross, but I love you too.
All right.
(upbeat music)